Folks,
it's official.
We are entering the age of unenlightened
meant my friend,
a true feminist in the best sense of the
word,
and a fearless defender of free speech.
Christina Hoff sommers was invited to
speak at Lewis and Clark law school this
week.
Here's what happened when she began her
talk.
Christina Christina,
victim mentality.
Microaggressions are real,
real,
real.
Putting aside the creepiness of the
comb,
like repetitive chanting from the
protesters.
Their use of free speech actually isn't
a use of free speech at all.
While of course they have the right to
protest your right to exercise.
Your free speech doesn't come at the
expense of someone else's right to
exercise.
There's so.
What this means is yes,
you can peacefully protest outside of an
event.
You can silently protest inside of an
You can hold all the signs you want and
you can encourage others to join your
cause.
You cannot,
however,
use your freedoms to trample on the
freedoms of others.
This chanting,
which again took place before Christina
had even begun to speak,
reminded me of when I was at Ucla with
Milo Yiannopoulos about two years ago,
protesters screen spit through garbage
cans,
pulled fire alarms,
and even called him bomb threats before
we even took the stage.
Perhaps most egregiously though was the
group of students who linked arms to
create a human wall to stop us and other
viewers from even going inside the venue
itself.
Apparently they aren't against walls,
they just don't like trump's wall.
Christina has continued through the
chanting and the protestors then broke
out in song.
We've gone side.
Which side are you on?
Fred's.
Quite a catchy tune,
wouldn't you say?
Of course.
Christina Hoff.
Sommers is in a fascist at all.
She's just an old school liberal who
dare challenge Modern Day leftism
ironically,
bs people so keen on fighting the fake
fascism in their minds,
don't understand that they themselves
are the ones who are actually using
fascist tactics of silencing and
drowning out their opponents until there
is no opposition remaining at all.
But if you're still confused,
here's a simple definition of fascism.
Fascism is a form of radical
authoritarian nationalism characterized
by dictatorial power,
forcible suppression of opposition and
Control of industry and commerce,
which came to prominence in early 20th
century Europe.
Do you think that Christina Hoff sommers
is for dictatorial power?
Is she for forcible suppression of
opposition?
To top it off,
she even works at the American
Enterprise Institute,
which is against control of industry and
commerce.
Now,
just think for a moment if the idea is
that these students were espousing were
the set of ideas and power,
they actually would be for dictatorial
control as they believed their cause is
the most just and their opponents are
simply evil.
How do you think it would be going for
dissent and opposition in their system?
Perhaps the most insidious piece of the
Cultural Marxism that we see spreading
on college campuses these days is that
it is using the freedoms that are
democratic capitalist society has
against itself.
Of course,
they would never offer these same
protections to minority voices in the
dystopian future that it would bring.
While this event thankfully wasn't
nearly as violent as when Milo went to
uc Berkeley and the school burned down
or when it took $600,000
of security to ensure that Ben Shapiro
could speak there without threat.
This display at Lewis and Clark is just
another reminder of how the backwards
thinking of Cultural Marxism is coming
for all dissenters cloaked in the mask
of tolerance and diversity.
These incidences are happening all over
colleges,
all over the country and turning places
of higher learning into places where
people are just getting high on
intersectionality.
Sadly,
this story really only broke on right
leaning blogs and was only shared by the
usual suspects who continually defend
freedom of expression.
As of recording this,
I haven't seen any left leaning websites
that covered it.
The reason for this,
of course,
is twofold.
On one hand,
when you can win arguments by silencing
your opponents,
your job is pretty easy,
but also,
and perhaps more importantly,
the good actors on the left,
which I still believe there are some who
want to call out events like this.
Rarely do because they know that the
same tactics of smearing and silencing
will eventually be used against them and
then there'll be purged from their
former home just as former guests of
mine like Bret Weinstein,
Laura Kipnis,
Lindsay Shepherd,
and others who dare speak out against
this tyrannical fo diversity movement.
The silver lining though,
of course,
is that the more that people like Brett,
Laura,
and others speak out,
the more room may give for people like
you to do the exact same in your life.
Speaking of Berkeley,
I spoke there yesterday with Heather
Mcdonald and Steve Simpson and I'll be
speaking at many other colleges in the
coming months.
Come join me wherever I may be an asked
me as many hard questions in the q and a
as you'd like.
I ask only one thing which is that if
you sing,
please make it a little snappier than
what we just heard.
A cover of journey,
fleetwood Mac,
or even Frank Sinatra would be
preferable.
Joining me today is the senior editor of
the Atlantic or contributor on MSNBC and
the author of the new book,
trump ocracy,
the corruption of the American republic.
David,
and welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm glad to have you here.
I wanted you on for a couple of years.
I think at this point you were a tough
guy to track down,
but we made it happen.
I'm find-able hiding yet.
You're not in hiding yet.
You couldn't be maybe by the end of this
interview because I let my guests talk
and you'd never know.
Right?
That's the twitter formula.
You're.
You're like 140 characters away from
career self-immolation yeah.
Well,
we've got about 60 minutes.
We'll see about emulation immediately.
All right,
so a lot of the things I want to talk to
you about.
I thought your,
your personal history is interesting and
usually when I see you on television,
you're talking about the day to day
machinations of politics.
You are Canadian.
I did not know that.
I find that I like Canadians.
Just everyone does.
Why are you people so agreeable?
Because we're so passive aggressive,
uh,
I grew up,
I grew up in Toronto.
I'm,
we have a place in Prince Edward County,
which is about two and a half east of
Toronto,
two and half hours east of Toronto where
my wife and I and our children are spent
summers now for almost three decades.
Um,
uh,
Canada's uh,
is,
um,
is a kind of mirror image of the United
States with some things,
omitted things intensified.
And so,
and I think it offers Americans often a
kind of,
um,
wha what if a examination of the,
of what the United States might have
been under different circumstances.
That's an interesting phrase.
What do you think's omitted and what do
you think is intensified?
Um,
so a candidate didn't have the American
south.
It didn't have slavery,
he didn't have a civil war.
Um,
Canada had a peaceful separation from
Great Britain.
So it doesn't have the,
it doesn't have the kind of citizen,
military traditions.
Canadians have a very different attitude
towards guns.
I mean,
they're,
my neighbors in Prince Edward County,
um,
all have,
are not all but many have long guns,
hunting pieces,
shotguns,
but the idea of having a handgun or a
military style weapon is a very alien
idea for Canadians.
Yeah.
You think some of the Canadian attitude
is also that there's a lot of geographic
space and not that many people actually.
Yes.
Um,
well,
there,
there it,
it
can be Kinda,
it can be kinda spooky at night.
I mean there,
there are great cities and Canadian
Canada is much more urbanized place in
the United States.
Canadians are more likely to live in
Toronto,
Vancouver,
Calgary,
Edmonton,
Montreal,
those places.
Um,
but uh,
there,
there's a,
I'm in a line from a poem.
The wild is always there.
And even when you live in the center of
Toronto,
you can be mauled by a lion.
You can head off,
you can start driving and pretty soon
you're in the wild.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So your mom was on the Canadian
Broadcasting Network
or company?
CBC.
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation
Corporation.
Okay.
Linda from tell me a little bit that was
Linda from is my sister who's a member
of the Canadian,
two things where the department know
now,
but she's a very prominent person to
learn from as a member of the Canadian
Senate.
I'm a leader in the Canadian
Conservative Party.
Um,
my late mother,
Barbara from was the host.
I it correct here to keep my biography
in your head.
I was just testing you on your own
biography.
Uh,
she was,
um,
a radio interview on a show called as it
happens for a decade.
Um,
and then,
uh,
was the founder of a show called the
journal,
which was one of those face to face TV
shows at a time when satellite in
satellite communication was quite knew
she died in 1992 at the age of 54.
Was Your family always political?
I mean,
it sounds like probably right.
Well,
my family was interested in politics.
My late father was a businessman,
not a,
not involved in the political world and
he had a lot of distance from,
from politics.
Um,
but yes,
I mean,
my parents dinner table was a place.
It was a high pressure environment.
They,
they,
they thought deeply about things,
but they were not ideological.
And one of the places where I really,
I mean learn to think was around that
dinner table because,
um,
you know,
my,
my mother is very skeptical about
everything,
including her own children and the way
she,
when you were saying something she
doesn't like,
but she would never argue with you,
but she,
you just set marching these two lines of
interrogatory questions and you would
eventually realized I'm caught between
these two lines and she would force you
to think more deeply about.
And not just political things but uh,
but everything.
Why do you do that?
Why do you say that?
Why do you think that's funny?
And,
um,
it made you a more conscious person.
Um,
and I try to live up to that and the way
I raise my own children,
you never try,
try never to tell them what to do or
what they,
what to think,
but instead to challenge them to think
and to think more deeply and not just
about the big things but everything.
Do you think that's what we're
fundamentally missing in society right
now?
I mean,
I think it's what I try to bring to this
show.
I try to let my guest talk even when I
disagree with them and maybe poke and
prod them in ways to,
to learn a little bit more,
but that everyone in the media these
days is just pounding at each other and
hitting each other and trying to destroy
each other instead of sort of going
along that journey with you and figuring
out why you think that way and more
importantly how you think.
I,
I think it's just human nature.
I think,
um,
I think it's human nature to be tough on
others and soft on ourselves and uh,
it,
it's a real discipline and um,
uh,
to say,
you know what,
maybe I should be soft on others and
tough on myself.
So there's an interesting story.
I want to get this totally right.
When you were 14 you volunteered for the
Ontario New Democratic Party.
Yes.
So far so good.
And for those who don't follow Canadian
politics as closely.
So the Ontario MD,
the NDP is the left party in Canada,
it's a multiparty system.
Um,
and uh,
a candidate of course has a
parliamentary system and there was a
provincial election and I was interested
in seeing how politics worked.
I wasn't,
I didn't really have political ideas,
but I was interested in campaigns and I
volunteered on that campaign.
So on that campaign,
you're 14 years old and on your commute
you're reading the Gulag archipelago?
Well,
we,
there was a,
it was a bus,
subway,
streetcar to go.
It was really something for a volunteer,
right?
It was summer holiday.
And so my mother had given me as a
birthday present,
I'm the paperback edition of the Gulag
Archipelago and urged me to read it.
And so I had a lot of time on that
commute and uh,
it had,
it hit me like a bomb.
Um,
and I,
I think,
um,
I mean my family in know are,
were not my parents got out of Europe,
my family,
my family's got out of Europe before the
war,
but they left people behind and so in
Polish.
So most of my father's family were
annihilated in the Holocaust and a very.
So that was something he was always very
conscious in my mind.
And then here was this other story that
I had not heard so much about it.
And it,
it,
um,
it shaped me.
How does that shape a 14 year old?
Well,
it,
um,
it would,
it makes you aware of is that human
history is very tragic,
um,
that you can't really rely that power
can be abused and it makes you begin to
think very hard about,
well,
how do we build a society?
So there I was on the Toronto subway
system in a society that really worked
and it forces you to think most
societies aren't like this in most
societies.
People are exposed to random terror and
too dictatorial power.
How do you make societies that,
that work in the protect people and
respect human dignity and human freedom?
Um,
so I began and of course at 14 you have
no answers,
but you made you become interested in
the question.
And what you also know is that when
people say,
I have a great scheme for humanity,
it just requires a few prison camps.
You learn,
you know what,
it's probably not such a good scheme,
right?
Although they usually don't tell you it
requires prison gifts.
It usually tells you it requires a lot
of good things,
right?
I mean,
isn't that the real trick?
But it generally.
But it tells you at,
I'm at you.
There are warnings early on,
um,
their warnings early on in any utopian
project like that.
We're going to have to,
you know,
break,
break some eggs here to make her an
Omelet at first year,
right?
At first the eggs or not.
Um,
and at first the eggs are kind of small,
but,
uh,
the first.
But you can tell those steps and that
one of the things that,
um,
you know,
uh,
I mean this is,
I think one of the reasons why people
look at what's happening on campuses
with such alarm.
Because,
you know,
obviously those are the people who are
shouting down people on campus.
They don't have police forces,
but they've made it pretty clear how,
if they ever did have a police force,
how they use.
Yeah.
So when I first came across you,
I think it was probably maybe 10 years
ago,
you were on realtime a lot and I would
say I would just see you on different
television and it was probably when,
for me personally,
I was a little more left than maybe I am
at the moment.
Um,
or at least the whole overton window has
just shifted that it's hard to put
anyone on a,
on the traditional map anymore,
but I always sort of,
you always struck me as like a sensible
conservative.
I never watched you and was like,
ah,
that's the guy I disagree with on the
right,
you know,
in some like crazed way.
What does conservatism because you,
you are a conservative,
right?
I would say I would use the adjective.
I am conservative.
I stopped using the noun.
A conservative.
Interesting.
That's an interesting distinction and
it,
it makes sense to me relative to so many
things changing right now.
What does conservatism generally meet?
Well,
I think it starts with the way our
brains are built,
that there are people who,
um,
are more conscious of risk and their
people are less conscious of risk that
people who hanker for change,
there are people who are ready to stick
with president evils rather than try new
ones and that's just a matter of brain
chemistry.
Then when people with those different
brain chemistry approach the problems
with society,
they start building systems of ideas.
So the reason I stopped using the phrase
a conservative and stopped talking about
the conservative movement is what I
would've called conservatives.
And when I came out of college in 1982
was a set of answers to the problems in
the 19 seventies and eighties inflation
crime,
Soviet menace,
the disorder in American life.
I'm sluggish.
Productivity growth and the
Conservatives have those days had a
series of policy recommendations for
those problems.
And by and large they worked and the
result was that the problems either were
overcome or anyway,
so reduced insignificance.
They stopped being the most important
problems that Americans cared about.
New problems came to the fore and about
those new problems,
conservatives had the same old answers
they've had back in 1982 and it became a
kind of fetish that if lower taxes with
the right way to respond to low
productivity growth in 1982,
then if you had completely different
problems in 2008,
then obviously still lower taxes.
Must be the same.
Must work just as well as they did with
a completely different set of problems
in 1982.
Um,
so I,
I think what has happened is that the
conservative movement,
conservative politics is a fossil.
It's,
it's,
it's interesting in that it reveal,
it's like an earthing,
some piece of rock from a different
geological era.
It tells you something about what people
had on their minds in 1982.
But if you say,
how am I going to solve the problems of
2018,
not so helpful.
Yeah.
So when people say that are
conservatives now,
does that have any particular meaning to
you?
Like,
I guess there is the set that you're
talking about from [inaudible] 82 that's
going,
you know,
what the answers are then,
but that seems very different from now.
And then of course,
we're obviously gonna spend a lot of
time talking about trump and that really
has flipped this on it.
This is what has made trump possible.
This is why the conservative movement
has sort of worked itself out of a job.
So the actual content of conservatism,
as you know,
what is conservatism have to say about
the opioid epidemic?
What does it have to say about,
um,
uh,
the great recession.
What does it have to say about the
collapse in life expectancy among non
college Americans?
What does it have to say about America's
place in the world in a,
in a world in which we're no longer
competing with an ideological nuclear
superpower of the Soviet Union,
but with,
uh,
with these opportunistic actors that
have like Russia and China,
um,
as conservatism has become more useless
to help those problems,
what,
what has been left behind is an
attitude.
What conservatism I think means to most
people say I'm a conservative because it
means anti leftism.
Find out what the,
what the American left is talking about
at any given moment,
and not only think the opposite of it,
but actually make your opposition to
that.
That group of people,
the organizing principle of your
politics,
you're sort of defining principle.
Basically you're defining principle.
Now what that does is first it makes it,
does a couple things.
First,
it makes oppositionists it means you're
always against never four,
and the second thing it means is you
never have the initiative because you
don't know what you think about anything
until somebody else tells you first.
And I think that's one of the reasons
why conservatives were so vulnerable to
trump,
is that you had an intellectual with
state that was largely untended and
falling into disrepair,
and Donald trump came and kicked the
door down and moved in.
Were there any candidates that you like
that of that crew before trump came in
and wreck the whole thing up?
Look,
there've been a lot of,
uh,
I'm,
I've almost always supported,
well until 2069,
always supported the Republican nominee
for president.
And um,
I thought there were,
there have been a lot of people who have
had real promise to make a good
president.
Mitt Romney would have made a very,
very good president.
Conservatism's problem.
A Republican isn't a problem,
has been that you take people who are,
have real promise as leaders and you
then connect them to a program that
can't win a democratic election.
Know since the end of the Cold War.
Conservatives want the,
the Republican nominee for president has
won a majority of the popular vote
exactly once and that was in 2004 in the
aftermath of nine slash 11.
Um,
it,
it's no longer,
there's no longer a national majority
for what Republicans are offering and
what has happened.
And it's no surprise because when you're
saying,
well,
our big ideas to take the medicare
guarantee away from everybody under 55
to put Medicaid on the path toward
extinction and to use all of that to
finance more tax cuts like those that
worked in the 19 eighties in a
completely different set of
circumstances that you're not talking to
or about me.
I'm so good.
People have been committed to an
unworkable program.
And what has happened then,
um,
has been that as Republicans have lost,
the parties become more desperate and
more vulnerable.
But what has also happened is that you
have had an increasingly self-conscious
move and the conservative world,
and this is part of the trump ocracy,
we'll talk about in the book to say,
well,
if we can't win a majority of the
people,
what we're going,
we're going to cope with that by
redefining who the proper people are.
And we're going to define the country.
We're going to shrink our definition of
who are the people and divide the
country between the people and those
people and the p.
and if we have a majority of the people,
that's all we care about and we're going
to try to find ways to prevent those
people from participating and even
voting.
So a couple of things here.
So it's interesting you mentioned taxes
a couple of times and generally
speaking,
when I have conservative sit across from
me there for tax cuts no matter what.
And that's what you were saying,
that there was the 82 crew basically
that was born and then this fossil
remained and people are always for it
now.
But it's,
it's rare to sit across from a
conservative.
And you're basically saying that there
are instances at least where the tax
cuts are not a problem.
Yeah.
But,
but,
but one of the really damaging things,
societies have states states need
revenue.
Um,
so,
um,
there are,
there are things,
there are ways,
you know,
the United States might not need so much
tax money if,
for example,
um,
it didn't spend twice as twice as much
per person on healthcare as everybody
else in the world.
When you look at the actual dollars
United States spends on,
on pro health provision for terrible
results,
um,
it's very expensive.
Um,
conservatives by and large are not
interested in getting their fingers into
that problem.
They're not.
So the government needs revenue and it
has to be funded and part of the
fossilization happens.
Conservative.
Say you say,
we've got a problem.
I'm whatever it is.
And the concern,
well,
if I can solve it with a tax cut,
then I'm for doing something.
If I can only solve it by having a
spending increase of that,
I won't do anything.
What then happens is cynical operators
say,
what if we take our spending increase
and instead of doing it through an
appropriation,
we do it through a tax credit.
How do you feel that?
Oh,
then I'm fine.
And the result is that wasn't the
problem is housing or higher education
or caring for disabled children,
that conservatives can be sold a
solution in the form of a tax credit,
which is usually the least efficient way
of solving a problem.
Um,
and the result is that you get this kind
of malformed state where the United
States has a really big and expensive
government,
but it's financed and especially in
efficient ways and it addresses problems
and especially inefficient ways.
So is the first part there though that
nobody actually cut spending,
you know,
I've had Ben Shapiro in here a bunch of
times and that's what he talks about it,
that we can keep raising taxes forever
and ever and ever.
But that really we have this just giant
monstrosity of a government that's
incredibly inefficient.
I mean even healthcare side,
just everything,
all the mid level bureaus and regulators
and just this massive federal government
that was never supposed to get so big
that we never actually really look at
how much of that we could chop away at
were then if we did a little of that,
we could have the,
the sort of relevant conversations about
tax cuts that you're talking about.
Well that's partly true and partly not
the United States.
Uh,
what is the government spend its money
on defense,
Medicare,
Medicaid,
social security.
I think that's those things together.
I think that's about 80 percent.
Um,
so,
uh,
the rest of the government,
you know,
is,
uh,
I mean,
I think it's true that dollar for
dollar,
the US government is less efficient than
that of other countries.
Um,
mostly because of the inheritance of not
having a proper civil service that I'm,
the idea that president starts off by
appointing the top 10,000
jobs in the civil service.
So it's highly political and you get a
lot of people who shouldn't basically
have no background in government,
don't know what they're doing and things
are not done in a very efficient way.
Also,
the power of Congress means there are a
lot of people were always trying to put
in some special benefit and things
happen that don't make.
So you have military bases in places
where they shouldn't be.
But if you were,
this is,
this is why I say conservatism is
obsolete if you want to reduce the state
share of expense.
And really,
I mean not just by repackaging things as
tax that are,
you know,
that um,
I mean,
one of the ways we,
for example,
fund the care of disabled children is
through a series of tax credits that are
not labeled as expenditures but really
are,
you have to do something by Medicare and
Medicaid.
And so the conservative,
the idea has been,
okay,
well the answer is we're going to take
away Medicare and Medicaid from people
and the reason that the Obama period has
been such a crisis and the period
afterwards is the defeat over the defeat
of the conservative attempt to repeal
the affordable care act.
And to pass the Ryan plan means the
conservatives have to face a world in
which the United States has joined the
other developed countries and having
something like or something closer to a
universal healthcare guarantee.
The old idea,
we'll save money just by not covering
people.
That is not going to be workable in the
politics of the 21st century.
So that means you have to actually pay
attention to how Medicare works.
And you have to say how while covering
everybody do we squeeze costs out of the
system and that requires a commitment to
policy detail that conservatives don't
like to do is they like the sweeping
comment.
We just need to cut all this waste.
But the,
when you say,
well,
where is the waste of Medicare?
Well,
the answer is,
would the United States,
um,
overpays for all of these services,
per unit,
um,
and uh,
doctors make more money in the United
States than they do in other places.
You have a,
you have these,
um,
uh,
but you also have this problem if you
have a sicker population than not people
do in other countries.
Americans die earlier.
They're less likely to wear seatbelts.
Um,
they have more gun accidents.
Uh,
you have to delve to deal with this
problem.
You have to delve into detail in a way
that the conservative preference for
ideology over factual specificity makes
conservatives not very useful at.
Is anyone good at that these days
though?
Really like really saying,
look,
if you look at the real grass root
movement on both sides,
I mean Bernie was pretty extreme left
and trump was w,
whatever I can,
it's hard to call extreme right,
but what we'll get into that,
whatever you call that,
that you know,
just the wrecking of the system.
So you had these two competing forces.
Look,
we have a lot of political messianism
that's a really important point.
But here I'm here.
Let me put a set of looking at what at
the two sides.
If you were to take the 5,000
people in the United States who know
most about Medicare and Medicaid are the
hundred who know most about Medicare and
Medicaid.
I'm guessing 90 of the hundred and 9,990
of the thousand,
maybe not 900,000
would be people of the center left
because conservatives just don't care
about that kind of knowledge.
And so they're always at a disadvantage.
So is it that they don't care,
they just don't think the government
should be involved in it like that.
The fundamental worst.
Well,
okay,
is that,
it's not the job of the government
really,
but they know,
so every once in a while somebody will
put his head above the parapet and say,
I don't think the government should be
providing healthcare for everybody.
Right?
You lose an election that,
that is how Donald Trump became the
republican nominee.
That's right.
Paul Ryan does not think the government
should provide healthcare to everybody.
The problem is the Republican primary
voter thinks the gut.
Well,
the government should provide healthcare
to everybody,
but they should provide healthcare to
everyone like me.
Um,
so,
uh,
yes,
they should provide healthcare to all
the over 65.
They should provide healthcare to all
the veterans.
But once you do that,
you're into a very big program.
And once you're saying government should
provide healthcare to all the over 65.
So that's where most of the spending
takes place anyway.
So
nuclear,
you have an ideological difference with
maybe the Paul Ryan approach,
but you think it's a legitimate of
looking at the
government,
right?
It's,
I don't want to put words in your mouth,
but I don't understand what that is.
It's a way to think,
yeah,
for sure.
Um,
you could argue that point,
but it's not a way that a political
party wants to compete for power in the
United States can think because the
voters won't accept it.
So what ends up happening is that the
Republicans have a bunch of commitment,
they have a bunch of theoretical
commitments and a bunch of operational
commitments and those,
they don't line up,
uh,
and in fact the Republican Party does
maintain Medicare.
It does make maintain medicaid and it
tries to find little economies usually
not very efficient ways,
but the result is because it doesn't
care about how those problems work and
it's not psychically committed to them.
There is no one there saying we're going
to cut.
We're going to.
How is it that Germany and France and
Switzerland,
the Netherlands,
Canada,
um,
cover more people have longer life
expectancies and spend less.
Um,
you know,
the difference between what the United
States spends the difference of the
American spending,
the American economy and healthcare and
that of the other developed countries.
It's about three,
three or four points of GDP,
which is bigger than the defense budget.
So what does that say then,
just about.
We don't even have to make this about
conservative per se.
What does that say about our system?
If a guy came up,
let's say a Republican nominee came up
and really was talking about that.
I talk that the,
the ins and outs.
I mean,
no matter what,
let's just look at 2016.
I mean,
he would have been clubbed over the head
by trauma and they still the trump
campaign.
Trump said trump is a.
was a great disco.
Trump.
This is what I mean by the hollowness.
So trump set,
I'm going to protect Medicare.
I'm going to protect Medicaid trump
campaign as the guy who's going to.
Who was the first Republican who really
made his peace with the American social
insurance system.
When conservatives said trump wasn't a
conservative,
they were right and that's why he beat
them inside their own party.
Trump begins by beating the republican
world.
He'd been.
He begins by defeating Fox News and
bending all of them to his will.
Now he had no idea what he was talking
about.
He had no plan for executing any of
this,
but he do.
You think that's really true because I
hear this with a lot of people that he
had either no idea what he was doing or
no plan or anything.
Someone who has no idea.
He reveals that every day he doesn't
know.
He doesn't understand,
but what does that say about all of us?
That's true.
Like if one of the.
One of the interviewers had said during
that Mr Trump,
you say you're going to preserve
Medicare and Medicaid.
What does Medicare do and what does
Medicaid do and what's the difference?
I will bet you I'm the amount of money
the Republican Party are going to
corruptly put in his pockets of Maro
Lago,
but he couldn't have answered that
question.
Yeah,
so that.
I completely agree with that.
I did a video before the election saying
if you want to stump trump asking him
what the three branches of government
are and what they're supposed to do.
He was asked what the three elements of
the nuclear triad.
Okay.
You didn't know that,
so that kind of stuff.
I do agree,
but this thing about sort of,
there was no plan.
There's no point in some way.
Even if even if I can intellectually get
there with you,
there's something about that idea that
then he duped by me.
It's scary.
I guess I would say it's pretty scary to
think that someone who had no plan dupe
the rest of us like that,
that inherently seems like a planet at
some level because we're sort of talking
about plans at different levels.
Well,
Don Donald trump is one of the great
scam artists of all time.
He scammed the people trump university.
He and the scan was possible because of
the disillusionment of so many people
with a responsible politics.
But what,
when he intuited,
I mean,
I mean he's not,
that he dumped trump has certain talents
and geniuses.
Um,
he,
he is a genius at finding the weakness
in things.
And he understood the weakness in the
institutional Republican Party,
which is that they were offering a
message that their own voters hate it.
And I have a lot of detail on that in
the book about how when you actually
showed Republican voters,
Republican primary voters,
what Paul Ryan wanted to do,
we just recoiled from it,
but he's gonna take away my medicare,
he's going to take away my mother's
nursing home.
That's the plan.
That's the famous Ryan plant.
So Donald Trump understood that.
That and what he then understood as well
was that in the absence of a program
that this anti leftism that can become a
conservative conservatism was this was a
series of resentments and rages that
we're waiting for somebody who could
articulate who,
who raged and presented as powerfully as
they did.
I mean Republicans,
the previous Republican nominees with
sometimes tap these feelings trying to
channel them,
but they didn't share them.
Donald trump shares them.
Okay.
So before we go fully into drop and then
we're going to spend the rest of the
interview on trump.
I just wanna talk a little bit about the
modern Democrats and the left in general
and all that.
So what do you make of the,
the feeling that he was going for?
I think that's a pretty legit feeling on
what's happened with the left related to
free speech and the endless hysteria and
everyone's a bigot and a racist and
identity,
politics,
all of that.
That feeling I think is legit.
Um,
do you see that as a legit feeling?
but in our group therapy that feelings
are legitimate.
The question is,
are not even feeling.
I see it as a legit reality.
The thing that he was talking about
there is a legit reality.
Um,
I will take this w what behind behind
all of those things you described is a
new fact and the politics,
the United States in the past 15,
20 years,
um,
which is that we are moving into a
period of intense intensifying ethnic
competition for power,
for money.
And for the right to say that,
what to talk about,
to define what it means to be an
American.
And the country's made this big gamble
on changing itself.
And across the developed world,
countries like the United States have
made similar gambles.
Um,
the proportion of the foreign born in
Sweden is now as high as in the United
States.
The proportion of foreign born in
Germany's nearly as high as in the
United States that are having massive
problems with their all immigration is
always a source of massive social
tension.
And um,
we do a lot of the immigration happened
without anybody ever consciously
intending it and without much of a
debate over it.
And with a refusal to tally costs and
benefits in an accurate way so these
countries have been changed.
And what you have is then a series of
new demands and new resentments.
And that's one of the,
one of the reasons that the conservatism
I grew up with the so out of date is
look back in 1985.
The argument between Liberals and
conservatives was basically an argument
about the economy that,
uh,
and this is true,
not just in every developed country we'd
have,
you had a party of the people who worked
for wages and the party of the people
who own capital assets and work for
salads.
The left were the people who,
whose jobs are supported by taxes.
The other people's jobs are supported by
profits.
If you're in management,
you were on the right.
If you are in a union,
you are on the left,
I'm not to sound sexist about this,
but essentially your relationship to the
means of production was the,
was this the organizing principle of
politics?
What also happened in 1995 was it people
remembered that this kind of politics
could spiral out of control and they'd
seen it happened in the 19 thirties and,
and uh,
you could get fascist movements,
you could get communist movements.
And so there were attempts to temper the
competition between the wage people in
the salary people between the owners and
the workers.
Um,
that's,
uh,
and so you had the,
you had kind of a continent.
The left accepted a market economy and
the right excepted to social insurance
state,
but that's what the argument was about.
And that's what we've run on now for
quite some time.
But that has ceased with the collapse of
socialism.
That argument ended.
Um,
the,
the modern left is not really a
socialist movement anymore.
There,
I mean people will sometimes use the
word they will have,
but I mean back in 1950 there are people
who really thought that if the
government owned the banks,
the banks would make better lending
decisions than they did.
Then they would have their private.
No one thinks that now.
I mean,
I don't even think really.
You don't think that there's plenty of
people on the left that we'll just sort
of incrementally get there.
They get 330 million people in the
United States,
so somebody who thinks every.
I don't even know him,
but I mean that if that.
If Bernie was president,
that eventually the EU.
I think the creeping movement of this.
Yeah.
Elizabeth Warren,
that do they want to movement?
I think Elizabeth Warren does not want
the government to own the banks.
No,
I don't think she.
I believe that Elizabeth Warren is not.
The government should own the steel
companies.
She doesn't believe that government
should own the commanding heights of
industry.
I'm sure she does not bladder that.
I don't know about owning,
but what about just controlling it to
the point where in effect it's
ownership.
I know,
I know you.
I know she thinks.
I don't think she thinks they should
manage it.
Um,
uh,
she believes in a social market economy.
I mean,
if you were to say to her what is the
best run country on earth?
She bringing,
always used to say Denmark was the best
one country.
Denmark is a free market society.
It's got a bigger social insurance
system in the United States.
And he said that because the reason he
said that was it was never serious
answer because he didn't stop caring.
But that's not what politics is about.
What politics is about is in 1985.
If I knew how you made your living,
I could probably guess how you voted
today.
If I know where your grandparents come
from.
I know how you vote.
So if your grandparents did not belong
to the local ethnic majority,
whether in the United States or Germany
or Britain,
you are in the party.
What used to be the lift if your
grandparents do belong,
did,
do,
or did belong to the local ethnic
majority of your,
what is the power of Party of the right
Houston?
And that's true,
however you make your living however
much or little money you have,
and that was not true in former days.
So you have this politics of ethnic
competition and that's why politics as
one,
the reason why politics are so much more
very long because in the end you with
money,
you can always split the difference
somewhere.
We say,
will you take 20 percent?
No.
Will you take 23 percent when?
Oh,
28 percent.
Okay,
we have a deal.
But when you're competing,
what does it mean to be an American?
We haven't.
Who gets to define Americanness?
Um,
we haven't found a way to split the
difference on that.
And until we do,
we're going to have very,
very little politics.
I mean,
there's this,
you know,
when,
when the Sarah payloads and others talk
about what it means to be a real
American and some things,
a real American,
other things are not looking for a way
to claim ethnic legitimation that we
get.
We may not have the numbers anymore,
but we still define the country and that
is one of the things that's going on.
That's what these political correctness
battles are all about.
I mean,
it's,
it's always true,
um,
that there are things people don't say.
They're always things that people don't
say.
Even if they're free to set their
things,
they don't say,
how does that happen though?
There things that you don't say and who
gets to decide.
And that's what we're struggling over
the people,
what we're calling political correctness
as people saying.
There used to be a set of rules,
a of taboos.
We have a new set of tools.
We want the old taboos to be unto Bu and
we want to impose the new Tibu and the
people on the receiving end of that say
we like our old taboos and we don't want
these new taboos.
And that,
that's where Donald Trump is coming
from.
I'm an,
if that's a real dispute is,
it's important,
but it's new and it's dangerous and we
don't know how to manage it.
And we have this deeply opportunistic
actor who's taking advantage of it.
Okay.
So before we fully dive into that then,
what does this show you that our,
our brand of multiculturalism,
which has worked better than virtually
any state,
you know,
European state
are our melting pot.
Does this tell you that the experiment
is starting to fail?
I mean,
is this the litmus test for that?
Well,
you know,
because that's what it sounds like.
First American melting pot never worked
as well as Americans told themselves it
did in other states.
I'm,
uh,
has had a lot of civic conflict and its
history and not just the civil war and
then later 19th century to the most
violent labor relations anywhere on
earth.
And those were often about ethnicity
that the strykers would be from one
group and the police police who shot
them would be from a different group.
And the strikes will be broken by strike
breakers who are from a third group yet
again,
um,
but multiculturalism is difficult to do
and it's especially difficult to do when
you have moved out of the age of mass
production and was one thing when you're
bringing in,
you needed a lot of bodies to run a
modern economy.
You don't need so many bodies today.
And uh,
and we also live in a world in which
whereas before,
um,
there were a lot of pretty average sized
rewards today.
We live in a world in which there are
gigantic rewards and not such great
rewards.
And the average,
what the average person gets is not as
attractive relatively speaking as it was
two generations ago.
All right,
let's do it.
Let's dive into this trump guy because I
sense that everything we've talked about
for the first half year,
a lot of your answers now are sort of
directly related to this guy who saw the
weakness but not to the
personality of this guy,
but to the whole system.
Well,
here,
let me,
I'll take one last attempt to do it on a
wider lens.
And then we'll go,
um,
you know,
I imagine
somebody standing on a timeline and the
center of the timeline is 1990 and uh,
they go forward 25 years,
2015,
and maybe they go to sleep and they wake
up.
Who are the most important politicians
in the country when they go to sleep?
Bush and Clinton,
who are the most important politician in
the country in 2015,
Bush and Clinton,
what are they talking about?
Iraq and healthcare.
Uh,
you go back 25 years from 1990 to 1965
and it's a different world.
There's an afl cio.
Uh,
there were riots in the cities.
There are liberal Republicans and
Segregationist Democrats.
So we have had this frozen politics for
a long time and it was ready to be
changed.
And Donald Trump,
the existing Republican party couldn't
cope with it.
And Donald Trump did.
He smash the system open.
So he's created some opportunities for a
new kind of political arrange,
an arrangement because the old one had
become so stale.
But what he's also done,
and this is the theme of the book,
is He's raising questions,
not just about the way we do politics,
but rather the whole political system
because he is a deeply authoritarian
personality.
His project is authoritarian and the way
he governs is not compatible with the
rule of law society.
It was going to happen one way or
another.
Right.
Do you think that's
fair to say?
Where is he so unique or that
personality trait or that,
you know,
the type of person that would be willing
to do it is so unique that we have like
trump,
like figures all over the western world.
Um,
you know,
we have a global crisis of.
Well I mean unique to our American
system because there was no one,
even though Bernie was actually talking
about rattling the system the same way.
And I think that's why there was some
crossover with their audiences.
We have people in,
I mean there's geared builders.
There is Marine Le Pen,
there's the alternative for Germany.
We just,
we're recording.
I'm just a few days before people see
this program.
There's an election in Italy in which
the traditional parties were swept aside
and I kind of joke party the five star
movement,
which was founded by a comedian and,
which is,
you know,
kind of,
uh,
an authoritarian populist party of the
left is now in league with,
um,
kind of neo fascist party and we are
seeing the breakdown of the traditional
parties of the center driven by slow
growth and ethnic competition.
Well,
that's what I'm saying was it gonna
happen no matter what,
even if trump had lost this election,
trump never rode.
So nothing is going to happen,
no matter what.
People make choices.
Um,
you know,
at the darkest moments in American
history in 1930 to 18,
60,
um,
political parties and political
movements converged on programs that
were constitutional,
that were liberal in the broadest sense
of the term.
And they found leaders who wanted to
uphold the American tradition and change
it enough that it could continue,
but without violating its assets.
This time it's as if huey long had
become president 1932,
not Franklin Delanor Roosevelt.
Okay.
So let,
let's just do like a couple minutes of
Russia so that we can get to that
because we can't talk about trump
without talking about Russia.
You tweet a lot about Russia.
Obviously you write about Russia like
you're talking about.
Do you absolutely believe that he
himself orchestrated or coordinated some
of this stuff with the Russian
government?
There remain many secrets in the Russia
story or there's no mystery,
uh,
the exact modalities of how the exchange
happened that remain uncertain.
But here,
here,
here is what I think I do know and I
think what unit,
um,
we know that Russia wanted Donald Trump
to be president and even more badly
wanted Hillary Clinton not to be
precedent.
Um,
we know that they intervened in an,
in a massive way and an industrial scale
and we're learning more and more all the
time.
How big was to hurt Hillary Clinton
first in the Democratic primaries to
help Donald Trump first in the
republican primaries and then in the
general election to help trump it
Clinton's expenses.
Can you give me just for people that are
playing total category?
So what are the examples of that?
Well,
let me.
Here's the most dramatic example.
Um,
uh,
the wiki leaks tropes are dumped in ways
exactly timed to help Donald Trump.
The trump people were expecting the last
wiki leaks stump of the election in the
first week of October.
They knew it was coming.
They expected to Donna about October
fourth or fifth.
It didn't come that day.
Instead,
it was dumped on October seventh,
within an hour of the access Hollywood
tape being broken by David Fahrenthold
of the Washington Post,
the,
the Russians or whoever controls wiki
leaks,
which I believe is,
I believe in Mike Pompeo.
The head of the CIA believes is weak.
Links is a cut out for the Russians have
not directly controlled by them.
They time their last Wiki leaks dump to
help Donald Trump should he have a
crisis in the election.
And it did,
um,
and it,
and I,
I,
in the book,
I sort of gave the minute by minute tick
tock where you see it seats,
um,
you know,
the Russians.
Would that help
God is the real question of whether the
campaign itself was coordinating that or
look,
we do all sorts of things with other,
with foreign governments and elections
and all kinds of stuff.
So whether,
whether the campaign actually was
coordinating it with a foreign
government,
which obviously we've done illegal,
we know that Donald,
as opposed to them just doing it and
having to work out for trump
to,
to Hakone Americans.
Email is a crime.
It's a big crime.
Um,
if you know that a crime has been
committed against Americans by you,
by a foreign government,
you would be annoyed about that,
especially if you aspire to be present.
United States the idea that Donald,
so we don't know to what degree yet.
We don't know to what degree,
if any,
people on his campaign work in regular
back and forth communication with the
Russians,
but he stood on a stage and in June of
2016 and welcomed the Russians breaking
American law to steal his opponents.
Email to his advantage.
His son took a meeting with people who
are offering him Russian hacked
information on Hillary Clinton.
They didn't do at the meeting,
the Russians didn't deliver,
um,
but you know it
well when we say the Russians,
we have to clarify between the
government and just other actors because
everyone says the Russians as it,
the lawyer one monolithic thing,
the true,
the lawyer who was at the meeting with
somebody with intense Kremlin
connections and who advertise that she
had criminal connections that she said
in the famous email to don Jr,
the Russian government wants to elect
your father.
I have information from the Russian
government.
It could help your campaign.
And he said,
great,
I love it.
Especially in the summer.
I am telling you that if an emissary
from the Russian government had
approached George W dot Bush in the
election of 2000 and said,
I have information on Al Gore,
that'll help you.
There wouldn't have been a meeting.
They would know a phone call to the FBI
and,
and there might even have been a phone
call to the Gore campaign.
You guys should know about this.
What do you think?
All right.
So.
All right,
so you believe that without question
there was coordinate?
No,
so I,
I believe the Russians helped and I
believe that Donald Trump is not a
belief.
It's on video.
You can look it up now.
Trump,
welcome to help and was ready to accept
the help,
um,
and a profit it from the help and that
and that.
And I believe it made a difference in
the election.
I believe also that there were Russian
attempts as far as we know,
they're not successful to interfere with
the actual mechanics of voting in a
number of states.
What?
Here's what I don't know.
I don't know whether information regular
information flowed back from the United
States to Russia after don junior is
meeting.
I don't know that.
I don't know whether the Russian
operation to influence the American
election benefited from any kind of
information provided by American
counterparts.
Those are things we don't know.
What I do know is that Donald Trump did
not act patriotically and he did not act
with respect to the American political
system and I will never get past that.
Do you think the Democrats have any of
the same dirt on their hands?
No.
Nothing.
I mean,
look,
it's,
it's not been bad.
Um,
they,
they did many,
uh,
they did many things.
I mean,
when,
when Hillary Clinton found,
um,
that a South American beauty queen who
is offended by Donald Trump,
do I,
is it possible the Clinton campaign paid
her money for her story as that's
possible,
but there's a difference between there.
I really do that there's a bright line
difference between the usual operations
of American politics.
It can be pretty rough and accepting,
help from the client,
the clandestine service of a foreign
government.
Wayne,
give you another example to make a
difference.
So in 2004,
it was no secret that gearhard
Schroeder,
Germany and Jacques Chirac,
the president,
France would dearly love to see John
Kerry beat George W dot Bush.
They made that very clear.
They gave interviews.
Uh,
they are very clear,
they are just counting the minutes until
Bush was gone and it was also clear in
2012 that Benjamin Netanyahu in Israel
preferred a net romney to Obama.
Either your allies have opinions.
It is.
None of those elections.
Did we have hostile foreign states?
China,
Russia,
Iran,
actors like that,
working,
not through talking to journalists,
but through clandestine intelligence
services to help one candidate and heard
another and have it all be visible and
have the candidate who was helped except
the help and imagine if if ran,
he tried to intervene in 2012 against or
for Obama or Romney and one of those
candidates had said,
you know,
Ryan,
if you're listening,
thank you for the help.
Inconceivable.
But that's what trump did.
He did it on video.
It's not a mystery so.
Right.
So I want to really talk about the
presidency and sort of the decisions in
that,
but to sort of get us to some sort of
ending with this.
If this all unfurls way I think you
suspect it will unfurl.
I mean I definitely would be for been
moved.
This is where it's going.
So let's start with the part that I'm
struggling with.
This is if we take all of the people
that talk about all of this,
it seems to me what we're talking about
is,
okay,
well you impeach trump and then really
then we have to do something which is
unprecedented.
Which is most likely pence knew
something and now you have to take the
whole administration out.
Now we suddenly have Paul Ryan as the
president or we have a Redo of the
election and then we're really at war
with Russia.
How trump has already changed this.
So no pre heat.
The Russia part of this is just one of
the things that have happened in no
presidents is Lyndon Johnson has
operated a business while president.
Nope.
No president in my memory has directed
his party's funds into his own personal.
About 80 percent of the money that the
Republican Party and spend on events I'm
in last year was paid at a Donald Trump
branded resort.
So this is like when they're holding
meetings at more or with.
A friend of mine sent me this clip,
George Schultz,
who was secretary of state under Ronald
Reagan,
had been an important executive maybe
ceo at Bechtel,
the giant engineering firm,
and that his confirmation hearing,
he was asked Mr Schultz after you become
secretary of state,
what would your relationship be with
Bechtel?
And he said,
well,
there's only one possible answer.
Nothing.
That's right.
That was the standard,
um,
so when you have is an attack on every
ethical norm of the US government,
both financial and national security and
the sea and half the country is being
born along.
Then the discussions we're having,
our discussions that I prompt in nine
slash 2013 as recently as that.
I said,
someday we'll be having these
discussions.
People think,
well,
we will be so far gone even to
contemplate.
So that is an unprocessable.
Um,
are we heading toward an impeachment
crisis?
Here's what were the crisis we're
heading toward.
And here's what I really,
one of my deepest worries,
I think we're,
there's a good chance we're going to
arrive at this place that Mueller is
going to report if he's assuming he's
not fired and he's going to discover a
lot of things that are violations of the
law done by mid level and even upper
level people.
And he may discover some financial
malpractices or a lot of laws about
things like declaring you're a foreign
agent,
that there are technical rules about
campaign finance and he will discover or
may infractions of those.
But the core thing and the Russian
matter that people like near concerned
about is probably not illegal.
It's probably not illegal for an
American politician to work with a
hostile foreign.
I mean,
no,
there isn't such a law and it's hard to
imagine what such law would look like.
And so where we may be a year and a half
from now is confronting this.
Donald trump worked in some way.
We may be,
I'm not predicting this,
I'm just hypothesizing worked in some
way with a hostile foreign intelligence
service,
but he himself broken a law and doing
that and now the country's going to have
to process,
um,
how to deal with that.
And it's going to be part of what is
going on in this new era which is
ripping apart the,
the,
the cords that bind us.
Because one of the things that makes a
country is the assumption how your
connections to your fellow Americans,
however much you may disagree with them.
And however you may have a different
color skin or have a different accent
from you,
that bond is more powerful than the
bonds outside the border.
And as American politics becomes
emphasized,
I think a lot of people were saying,
my connections with this global movement
of reactionary populace forces are more
powerful than my bonds to fellow
Americans have different skin and
different accent.
And because of that,
unless you could show me that Donald
Trump literally broke a federal criminal
statute,
I don't mind what he did.
So how do we get out of this?
How do we get out of either that
inevitability or do doing,
just ended up literally fighting on the
street?
The way we get out of it is we have to
venue American nationhood.
Um,
and so we have to do,
if we get out of this,
we're going to do something.
Some are going to sound pretty liberal
and some are going to sound pretty
conservative.
I believe we need a lot less immigration
because that's,
you have to,
we have to make a nation.
Again,
we've taken on a lot of new people.
Um,
and I,
I'm,
I'm a naturalized citizen myself.
I grew up in Canada and my family is
from eastern Europe.
Making nations is hard and time
consuming.
Um,
so that's the conservative part of the
part you need to say that sounds pretty
trumpy it actually,
you'll have the whole left and at
virtually every Democrat against you
that you need a thicker social insurance
network.
Um,
you need,
you need a real healthcare system
because what we have to deal with,
we have to deal with the crisis in life,
expect we have to care for each other
more.
Um,
the idea that we went through in the
whole second Obama term,
people who didn't graduate from college
living less long than their parents,
which literally did not happen in the
Great Depression.
And not only did nobody do anything but
no one even noticed.
This was founded by pair of economists
who happened to look at some data.
There's no one was paying a lot of
attention to this.
The opioid epidemic erupted with no one
in Washington paying much attention to
it.
Um,
we need,
uh,
we're going to need to build a stronger,
a stronger sense of national identity
and,
but it's going to be a different kind of
national identity is not going to be
Sarah Palin's America,
but we have to,
we're going to have to find some way of
agreeing what it means to be an
American,
what it means not to be an American or
whatever it is,
the inherent problem there that were
caught now between trump and sort of the
democrats that love identity politics.
And neither one of those is giving us
the answer to that.
I mean,
where is the voice?
That's where is the political voice
that's saying exactly what you just
said.
Look,
we've been here before,
um,
you know,
that melting pot story that you were
told it wasn't true at the time.
It was a myth we created later.
Um,
when the United States entered World War
One,
the biggest minority in the country was
one of the biggest with German speaking
Americans.
Um,
and there was real doubt about what the
United States would be able to fight
Germany in the first world war because
the German Americans might be disloyal
and the country went on a ramp,
I mean a band,
German language,
newspapers that suppressed German
language schools.
And it wasn't a melting pot.
It was a harsh and rancorous process.
And the United States had in the 19th in
the immediate aftermath of world war,
one of pogroms in American cities that
were very against by white Americans
against blocks that were deadlier than
the antisemitic programs that took place
under the czar.
Um,
uh,
those were facts of our history and
other that we built.
But I'm in the years after World War Two
and for half a century after a strong
sense of national identity,
we have to do that state building and
nation building process again.
And some of it's going to not look.
I is going to look out partly liberal,
partly conservative.
Um,
but it's going to be a new politics for
a new century.
And the idea that people are going that.
And if anyone is standing around saying,
I don't know,
I think I prefer the problems of 1982 so
I can have the solutions of 1982.
I mean,
you're just not helping.
What would you say to the people that
would say,
and this is a little bit more where I
fall in all of this,
that the government is just not the
answer to any of these things that I
hear you on all of these problems
without question,
no doubt.
Um,
but that to me at this point that
everything you're talking about,
he's showing me the government no longer
functions this,
the federal government specifically no
longer functions in a way that it can
cope or deal with any of these things we
get then bad actors that want to wreck
the whole thing.
Or we get these mid level management
people that never really do anything and
that you could look at virtually every
member of Congress that all the answers
that you're asking for,
I would argue have almost nothing to do
with the government.
And that there's other ways now,
especially because of the Internet and
everything else.
There's other ways that we can connect
and build things.
Right now.
Elon musk is the guy that's getting us
into space.
Warren Buffet's working on an alternate,
um,
healthcare plan,
you know,
like that there's just other ways to do
this and that,
those machines,
they can't work anymore.
Looks something.
A lot of the great social
transformations have in the American
history is different from that of other
countries in this way that oftentimes
the way the country is addressed,
the most effective cultural change in my
lifetime was prompt with mothers against
drunk driving.
Um,
that changed Americans' attitudes.
They changed laws to.
I mean the,
the government,
the state has a role.
Um,
I,
I think for things like the gun debate,
I mean that I think that is going to be
ultimately addressed if it is addressed
not by state action brought by private
action,
which is whatever the laws are.
Just if you,
if you have kids and you care about
them,
don't have a gun in the house,
you know that justice mothers against
drunk driving change.
The idea that it was funny,
drunk driving was funny too.
The idea that it was not funny,
so we have to change the idea that if
you're a responsible parent,
your arm to,
um,
a new better understanding that if
you're armed,
you're not a responsible parent a,
but
the Conservatives won't be happy here
you say.
That's right.
A lot won't be,
but
it's true.
It just happens to be.
What's the saying?
The facts don't care about your
feelings.
It's just a fact.
I'm a,
I think ben would argue with that fact,
but maybe we can do that,
but we will be sensitive feelings.
Uh,
but then of course you had the
government has to do this and it's true
that dollar for dollar and pound for
pound,
the American government has always been
less effective than other governments.
But sometimes it's more effective and
sometimes it's less effective or things
that the government is going to have to
do.
Um,
and the government doesn't have to
administer the healthcare system.
I would hope it wouldn't.
There's a role for the profit motive and
for competition.
But the idea that we're going to accept
a country in which large numbers of
Americans are uncovered are outside the
healthcare system and um,
that people literally die because they
get,
they can't afford dental care and their
teeth fester and fester and gets into
their body and it kills them.
That has to change.
And that the role of the state is part
of,
if we're going to have a new ethic of
nationhood without higher border and
more mutual care.
Um,
yeah,
of course governments going to be part
of that.
And by the way,
not that that only the federal
government because a lot of the.
I mean the country is big.
I mean a running California is
challenged enough.
So since you don't say you're a
conservative specifically anymore,
I mean,
what if people are listening and going,
I get this.
It's a little bit of both because
there's a lot of big government here.
There's,
I know you're saying you would prefer
the government not have to do health
insurance,
all that.
You're,
you're,
you're sort of all over the place right
now.
Which I think a lot of people are.
I think that's the situation we're in
right now.
Um,
what do you call that now?
Not that.
And I only ask about labels because
although they're becoming increasingly
meaningless,
I think it helps people go,
all right,
this is my starting point.
Well,
I,
I don't have a label for it because I
think this is one of those moments in
American history where you have to do
something new.
Um,
you know,
for,
for 25 years after the civil war,
Americans kept arguing both about the
civil war and about its financial
consequences.
And then they began to notice that in
the aftermath that they had these big
cities grow up that were intensely
corruptly governed.
And I'm a new new movements came along
and said,
uh,
we have.
It's not like the legacy of the civil
wars is resolved.
It's still not fully resolved.
But in the meantime we have to figure
how do we get streetcars in New York?
How do we get the water clean?
Um,
how do we make sure that the older men
are and aren't taking bribes and that
new political.
And at first they weren't,
they just knew what the problems were
and as they worked on the problems,
they develop labels to describe what
they were doing.
But first you start,
I think one of the ways that,
um,
especially on the right,
one of the,
one of the ways that we go wrong,
it's a new problem is presented to us
and instead of looking at the problem
studying it,
we reach for volume of the Talmud and we
say,
what did rabbi I'm Russell Kirk say
about this three quarters of a century
ago?
Oh,
he never talked about it,
therefore we can't do anything about it.
I feel good about this.
And I feel like you've presented it.
A couple of interesting ideas that I
haven't,
that I haven't quite talked about here.
And you're coming at it from different
angles.
Is there anyone that's doing this
politically?
I mean,
who are the people that you right now
think are making?
We're doing it right now.
You and I and um,
and I think,
look there,
there are a lot of things that come out
of the trump era that are actually good.
They're prefers gifts that he's given
us.
One of them is by lying all the time.
He's helped us understand how important
it is.
The people tell the truth when you know
you're concerned about what goes on on
campus.
You know the phrase post-truth began as
a compliment,
not a criticism.
It began by,
by people who wanted to overthrow
totalitarian truth structures and open
the way to many multiple truths.
And they discovered that when you do
that in politics,
but you don't get the opposite of truth,
isn't truth.
The opposite of truth is lying.
We've seen rising levels of civic
engagement and we,
I think we are seeing,
especially among the young,
a sense that the political categories
they've inherited are obsolete.
Yeah.
And they have to start looking at
problems a new,
uh,
and that they have to be begin with the
problems and then develop the solutions.
And then people will disagree with a new
party system will come from is,
you know,
as we really contemplate,
how do we improve the health outcomes of
our fellow citizens?
How do we deal with drugs?
How do we deal with a declining life
expectancy of those who don't go to
college,
they're going to disagree and then
they'll find like minded groups and
they'll end up inside the Republican and
democratic parties.
Those institutions will always be there.
The content will change.
And,
and along the way we'll find new names,
but anyone politically,
I think I appreciate the compliment and
I think there are some people that are
trying to make some sense these days,
but really,
I mean,
do you think anyone politically,
I think it will start at the state
level.
Um,
you know,
I think the mayor here in Los Angeles as
an example,
someone who's trying to figure out how
things work.
Andrew Cuomo in New York,
I'm in kind of a bully,
but he cares about why does,
why does it cost three times as much or
whatever it is to build a subway in New
York as in London.
Um,
and um,
so I think this,
the regeneration of the American
political system has always come from
cities and states and I think that will
be even more true in the 21st century.
A man here in California,
what you need,
you need a revival of political
competition.
Uh,
one of the reasons why I stay a
registered Republican is you.
I look at California and say,
this is what happens when you get a one
party state.
You get factional politics.
It doesn't mitigate the problems of
ethnically driven politics.
It makes them worse.
So we're gonna need,
we're gonna need two party competition.
We're going to need a new solutions.
And that's what,
that's what I try to do in my work is to
try to offer,
you know,
the,
the possibility of a more useful kind of
politics.
It's interesting because,
I mean,
that's exactly what I tried to do with
the show.
And even last week I had Mike
shellenberger on who's running as a
Democrat,
you know,
he,
he's more of an old school Democrat and
he's into nuclear power and all sorts
of new ideas and using technology to
solve our problems running against Gavin
newsome,
who is,
who's the hero of the left than he
thinks he's too left.
And then this week I have you on to
discuss your frustrations with the
Conservatives and all that.
So that's.
This is what we have to keep doing.
At the end of the day,
that's all we got,
right.
That's,
that's what I was.
And as long and we have to defend our
ability to do that and defend that both
against those who would use violence and
against those who would use corruption
to try to shut down proper discussions.
Perfect.
That's a perfect ending right there.
Thank you for though,
I suspect.
Yeah.
My pleasure.
I suspect we'll do this again.
Maybe we'll,
we'll get ben in here and we'll do that
little facts over feelings,
things that we get a couple of other
people in here to to mix up some of
these ideas for more.
David,
follow him on twitter at David Frum and
check out his book,
trump ocracy and the link right down
below.